(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Minneapolis is bracing
for the high profile
trial of Derek Chauvin,
the former police officer
charged with second degree murder
and second degree manslaughter
in the death of George Floyd.
- You're resisting arrest
- I cannot breath
- [Unseen Female] Are you having fun?
- [Unseen Male] You're a
grown, you're a tough guy.
- Video of the incident
in which Chauvin is seen
kneeling on Floyd's neck,
While, Floyd repeated
that he couldn't breathe
sparked worldwide protests and
launched a national reckoning
over police brutality against black people
in the United States.
- Say his name! George
Floyd! (people chanting)
(somber music)
The trial will be live streamed
and authorities expect it to
inflame tensions once again.
More than 3000 law enforcement officers
and national guard troops could be
on call as the jury deliberates.
- This is a difficult
case in so many ways.
People around the world
have seen this footage,
but people in Minneapolis
have seen the footage
and what it's done to the city.
I mean, you had riots
a billion dollars worth
of damage to businesses.
1500 businesses were
somehow impacted by this.
- We recognize that
throughout the trial itself
people will want to gather,
they'll want to protest.
They'll want to express
their first amendment rights.
And we want to enable them to
do so safely and peacefully.
- [Narrator] Due to concerns
surrounding COVID-19
and social distancing
Chauvin, will be tried alone.
His lawyer has made filings
indicating he's not guilty.
(suspenseful music)
So, what kind of evidence
will be presented?
Who might testify?
And what is the bar for conviction?
Here are three things to
know about Chauvin's trial.
First video evidence is expected
to play a significant role.
The prosecution is likely to seize
on the footage that shows Chauvin kneeling
on Floyd's neck for around eight minutes.
As prosecutors have pointed out previously
Chauvin continued to
kneel on Floyd's neck,
for about four minutes
after an officer said
Floyd was passing out
and for two and a half minutes
after another officer said,
Floyd did not have a pulse.
- [Policeman Kneeling] Relax!
- [Man On Ground] Man I
can't breath (mumbles)
- I think those last
minutes after he's already
no longer not only not moving,
but they can't even find a pulse,
how the jury is gonna react
to seeing that again in court
is probably one of the
big moments of the trial.
- [Narrator] The defense may also use
video evidence to bolster its case.
Though, it is likely to focus
on what happened before
those final minutes.
- [Policeman] You got 'em?
- [Floyd] Dang man.
- [Policeman] Put your
hands on top of your head.
- [Narrator] Chauvin's
attorney has previously argued
that police body camera
footage shows Floyd struggling
and actively resisting arrest.
- [Policeman] Stop resisting then.
- [Floyd] I'm not.
- [Policeman] Yes you are.
- [Narrator] The defense
has also pointed to footage
of Floyd saying he couldn't breathe
before he was ever on the ground,
as evidence that serious medical issues
were the cause of his death.
- [Floyd] I can't
breath! (mumbles) Please!
(somber music)
- [Narrator] Medical evidence,
will also feature prominently in the trial
but the jury may hear
conflicting testimony
especially because two
different autopsies determined
that Floyd's death was a homicide
but gave different reasons for his death.
- The defense only wants to
have the official medical
examiners report,
which talks about George Floyd dying
because of cardiac arrest,
complicated by the police
trying to arrest him and subdue him.
And then also mentioning
that he had fentanyl
and methamphetamines
and a heart condition.
- [Narrator] Chauvin's attorney
has pointed to that autopsy
to argue that Floyd couldn't
breathe due to a lethal dose
of Fentanyl and possibly a speedball,
and that other pre-existing
conditions combined
with the drugs most
likely led to his death.
But another autopsy
prepared for Floyd's family
came to a different conclusion,
that he died of asphyxiation
at the hands of the police.
- Well, I think the question
the two sides are gonna be
going back and forth on is,
what's standard procedure
and what is police training.
- So what is the bar for a conviction?
The most serious charges Chauvin is facing
is, second degree unintentional murder.
That means prosecutors don't
need to prove intent to kill
but they must prove beyond a
reasonable doubt that Chauvin
intentionally inflicted
substantial bodily harm to Floyd,
which resulted in Floyd's death.
- What they are actually
trying to prove is that
in the course of him being
assaulted by the police, he died.
So the police didn't intend to kill him
but by assaulting him,
it led to his death.
- [Narrator] Chauvin's attorney argued
that the officers
properly restrained Floyd
because he was acting
erratically and posed a risk
of injury to himself and
potentially to the officers.
- It really is a difficult
thing to come to grips with
because everybody's seen this video
the officers were all fired immediately
but it's still very difficult
to prosecute a police
officer in this country.
- [Narrator] Legally, the stakes are high.
If Chauvin is acquitted,
the three other officers
may not go to trial at all
for aiding and abetting him.
Currently, that trial has
been delayed until August.
Lawyers for the three,
have made filings indicating
they aren't guilty.
(somber music)